feminists are probably some of the most
arrogant people you'll ever meet as
weird as this sounds they're not
tolerable they don't like to tolerate
anybody that disagrees with them they're
arrogant they think they know it all
they're annoying to be around they're
constant
I put an event together such a weird uh
thing happen at the Vault
um we're at the Vault conference and
first night I'm giving assignment for
people to go answer these questions so
the next day they come out and I said so
tell me what's your breakthrough you had
last night what decisions did you make
anybody's giving me theirs and then all
of a sudden one lady to my right she's
kind of like trying to put her hand up
but she's not and then she finally puts
out I said you want to go so go ahead
tell us what was it for you so she
stands up she says you know what Patrick
uh I've been running a salon one of the
best I'm great at what I do all my
people make a lot of money we do very
very well and I've done very well for
myself and her sister sitting right next
to her but she says I make money I have
money
and I'm sitting here telling you
I want to get married no I want a man
yeah I want a family
and she gets emotional she says I no
longer want to compete against a man
I want a family
and the entire crowd
quiet
it's like she just said what like who
needs to hear that millions of people
need to hear that today right and you
see these 65 year old women videos going
viral where they say I walked with the
feminist I bought into the argument
being a feminist man was an enemy in my
life
this lady says this was the most
touching lady she was not a good talk or
not she wasn't like she just regular
talking she's I'm 65 years old I've
never been married I have no kids I will
never be able to have kids I will never
be able to experience what it is to be
married to a man when I was in my 20s
the concept of feminism stole that away
from me
just because I looked at man as the
enemy and he's not
and a lot of people are going to go
through this and it's gonna suck because
this thing goes like this I'm 44 years
old right I look at my hands like this
like this I look 22 right I look young
like this but like this I'm 44 years old
okay this hand didn't look like this
when I was 22 years old I'm 44 I got
four kids at the house you know my dad's
80. I look at my dad when he walks right
now I'm like man you didn't walk like
that before and I see his back and he's
walking like a and my son tries to mimic
out his grandpa walks it's funny but at
the same time you're like this guy's got
a hunch in his back this thing goes by
very very quickly if there's one thing
we cannot do is screw up the family
nucleus of what it's like because okay
let's just say you come home you're a
billionaire and you don't have kids that
lives past your life you don't have
somebody to share it with let's say
every night you sleep with somebody new
okay cool let's role play that every
night first night Mary second night
Jennifer third night Jackie fortnite
Cindy how many nights can you go like
that okay cool it's bragging rights
maybe for a year two years cool I've
been with this many
who the hell you having conversations
with like what do you think like for me
my high is
we work we go to dinner we sit down we
have an incredible conversation together
right
that is an incredible feeling with
friends same people preferably because
it's getting deeper and deeper a spouse
your kids your family that's emotional
that's why we live oh believe me it gets
me emotional as well you have no idea
how much I like yesterday I'm sitting
there watching Rocky IV with my kids
and I said kids let me tell you
something I said what do you think about
this movie my tikon Dylan afterwards it
sounds like punch him punch him hit him
hit him hit him he's getting all into
he's getting animated and he says Dad
this is one of the best movies of all
time I said it's the best movie he says
no Pearl Harbor is the best movie but
this is the second best movie of all
time so we're sitting afterwards so tell
me what you took away from this movie
and they're telling what they're saying
I said you guys have to realize this I
said when I watch this movie I was seven
years old the first time I watched it I
was in Iran and my mom said they were
Communists my dad said they were
imperialist it was as if this movie was
about my mom and dad where they would
fight all the time and his message was
trying to figure out a way to see what
things we have in common but I said
everybody's a rocky we all got big
dreams don't ever let anybody steal that
dream away from you but I enjoy
relationships I enjoy all of that and
unfortunately this feminist movement is
hurting us having relationships and
knowing that I got strengths you don't
have you don't you have strengths I
don't have but what if we work together
we can do something big together again I
don't think it's sustainable but I do
think it's going to steal away a lot of
people's dreams unfortunately I think
that was uh no said really well I think
that um I'm blessed to know that
feminism is a scam like at this stage
I'm blessed because I totally agree with
you I think you do reach as a woman you
do reach an age and you know you're just
sort of like is that entirely satisfying
like is that what it's going to bring me
absolute happiness and you're sort of
not allowed to talk about that you know
there's a lot of shaming if you're a
stay-at-home mum but I agree with you I
think there's a massive war on the
family unit but it's but it's not just
feminism there's
the feminization of men
so they're trying to make men more
feminine so that women then have to rise
up to to fill that void and provide for
themselves
um so so how do we solve the
feminization of men so for some people
it's too late you can't do nothing about
it like you see right now Dwyane Wade's
ex-wife is suing him for forcing his son
to go through the you know trans you
know surgery before he's 18 years old
and they're going back and forth and
some are saying you know Dwayne's doing
it because he's choosing career because
he's about to get a big deal with Disney
versus this I think that kid is done I
think that kid's going to buy into what
Dwayne Gabriel Union or selling to him
he's unfortunately going to be in and
he's going to lose 10 20 years of his
life most likely that's the odds that
one's gone
uh I think the kids that are going to be
raised in parents whose uh you know Mom
Mom Dad that they're they're gonna be
they're gonna be it's gonna take them a
minute for them to find themselves you
know I I knew a guy that ended up
becoming a pastor who's a mom was a uh
was a lesbian and was also with a his
wife her wife so it was very confusing
for this guy took him till 35 years old
to kind of figure himself out still
loves mom and his both moms whatever the
relationship was but at the same time he
took uh figured out a way to figure
himself out
[Music]